hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach today I will talk about the
definition of done the definition of
done is a documented team agreement it
defines the conditions that must be met
for a potentially shippable product to
be considered dumb isn't done it's how
we know that we did the thing right
meaning we built in the correct level
quality into the product these are
distant from the acceptance criteria
which are written by the product owner
and help us know that we did the right
thing creating and following the
definition of done diligently can easily
double the speed of an agile team lean
practitioners will tell you that in the
long run quality is free because if you
don't build a quality product in the
short run you're going to pay for it in
the long run due to increased technical
debt the slow pace of manual testing and
production bugs having lots of hidden
undone work in your product will make
releasing your feature to customers
difficult and risky scrum doesn't talk
about this much detail but many less
mature teams use two sets of definition
it done one is targeted at what you will
consider done for a single product
increment that you are bundling in to
release the other is the definition of
done for that entire release over time
you want to improve your practices
environment and team structure so that
you can potentially release any given
product increment at any time so what
should you include in your definition
are done a lot of minimum you're going
to want your work to be code complete
unit integration and performance tested
you want to have just enough
documentation no new bugs or technical
Deb and lastly accepted by the product
owner is meeting the acceptance criteria
I suggest bending an hour as a team to
review sample definitions of time and
craft around then review your definition
design periodically so it's is it your
team's retrospectives at the beginning
your definition have done may have just
a few items
and as your team an automation matures
expand your definition of dumb to
include more scope